So the process of producing
the dual of a linear program
is just a mechanical process.
There's a series of steps that
you go through where each
constraint from the primal becomes
a variable in the dual and
each variable in the primal
becomes a constraint in the dual.
And certain maxes become mins and
bounds become objective function things.
So what I've done here is I've
actually gone through that process,
which we could go through in detail,
but let's just pretend that we did.
[LAUGH] And we create a new linear
program from the old linear program and
the new one is called the dual.
So let's take a look at
this dual in detail.
Because it turns out that the variables
and the constraints actually have some
very nice interpretations that
are worth thinking about.
Here in the dual, the thing that we're
trying to optimize is we're trying to
maximize the sum over all
state-action pairs of the reward for
that state-action pair times
this value little qsa.
So little qsa,
probably not a great name for
it because it's not
the same as a Q value.
But it's something.
It's something that we're
multiplying by the rewards and
we're trying to maximize it.
So one way I like to think
about qsa is as policy flow.
Sort of how much [LAUGH] agentness is
flowing through each state-action pair.
If it follows the policy it's
going to spend some time
running around in the environment,
passing through each state-action pair.
And each time it passes
through a state-action pair,
we're going to get the reward
associated with that state-action pair.
And what we want to do
is maximize that reward.
So from this sort of,
policy flow concept,
it sort of makes sense what it
is we're trying to maximize.
It's in some ways even more
intuitive than in the primal,
which we were saying we're
trying the minimize the value,
which of course we're not really
trying to minimize the value.
We're just trying to minimize it so
that it doesn't end up being
an upper bound on the value.
Here we're actually trying
to maximize expected reward,
which seems like a really good thing.
>> Right, right, right.
>> Okay so this is now going to
be subject to the following idea,
that for each state, in this case it's
easier to think of them as next states.
For each possible next state,
we want it to be true that the amount
of policy flow through that next state
summed up over all the actions
that are going through it.
That should be equal to in some
sense the number of times that
next state is visited,
which we can get by summing over all
states we might have started at, and
actions we might have taken form there.
The policy flow through that
state-action pair times
the transition probability that would
send us to s' as a result of that.
And we're going to also
include in this equation
sort of the sense that we can also
start a given state-action pair.
So we're just going to stick a 1 in for
that.
So there's some policy
flow that we're injecting
into each state-action
pair of the system.
And we're going to add to that any
policy flow that would be coming through
it through other parts of the system.
So it's kind of like we're dumping
policy flow all over our MDP.
And then letting the MDP kind
of pump around what's left.
And it's discounted,
there's a little discount here.
So there's actually evaporation or
something happening all over the place.
And what we want to know is what's
the way of letting the flow go through,
kind of deciding at each state which
action it should flow through, so
that we ultimately get
the maximum possible reward.
And I think just one
additional constraint here,
just to make sure that the policy
flow is not negative, so
that we can't introduce a whole
lot of policy flow in one place.
And then drain it out some other
place to make things balance.
You could think of these constraints
as actually being a kind of
conservation of flow.
So the amount of stuff going into s'
has to equal the amount of
stuff coming out of it.
And that's all this is saying.
It's just saying that
that has to balance.
It has to be a meaningful flow.
Subject to that constraint,
maximize reward.
So, again, this is kind of a neat
interpretation of what it means to
solve a mark off decision process.
But it just comes mechanically
out of the primal version of
setting up this as a linear program.
>> Okay, does that suggest an algorithm
that's different from the sort of
algorithms you've been using so far?
>> Hm, interesting thought.
So, well for one thing, it is an
algorithm in the sense that once we set
things up this way, we can hit
it over the head with the linear
programming stick and
a solution will come out.
>> And in fact, it'll come out in
polynomial time, which is nice.
But you're right.
I mean in some sense, if you think
about value iteration as something
that's propagating these values around,
this has a different form.
This is really concentrating more
on the policy aspect of the MDP.
And maybe we could make an algorithm
that more directly kind of
searched in policy space for
the best behavior for the MDP.
>> Let's do that.